it's finally
time to ask about having ally
incorporated in the show and i'm i'm so
excited
um for both of you so whoever wants to
chime in on this one
i know for a while everyone's been
denying whether or not elizabeth shoe
was confirmed to return
but when did you guys get the official
news that that it was really going to
happen
it was pretty close to when we were
shooting we knew it was all in the works
and
uh you know the but the teas were
crossed and eyes were dotted
not long before you know she arrived
um so it was during the season unless
billy billy might have known a year ago
the year before that but i you know it
was always there was always a backup
plan
and a backup uh ending
um that they you know there was a hard
out date where they needed that decision
and it was right up to that
to the clock striking 12. so um but it
was a
big relief and and we got to uh
all tango together again and it was
really you know it has like i said has
that
there's some connection that's bigger
than us
with this cast we hoped that she'd be
back we knew it i i bumped into her at
comic-con in san diego uh
last year before the year before we were
shooting it
and uh she had the guys had been in
touch with her about coming back and she
was
she was entertaining it and seeing her
it was kind of a nice moment for us to
just reconnect as people and friends
from so long ago
and then uh then the the guys told us
what the pitch was for the story but she
was
she approached it the way we did i think
at the very beginning of this where
she's very protective of the character
and wanted to be represented correctly
and
for her to you know not just be uh you
know
thrown into the show for the sake of
saying there's ally but that she has a
good story
and all those things lined up and it was
awesome working with her and uh
it was like old times like ralph says
just like reconnecting with old friends
and and
as artists uh it's it's very natural and
picked right up you know it's great
you feel that too and you're watching it
like you're basically just doing a
direct continuation from what you guys
started so many years ago
of everything you guys got to film
together is there a particular beat or
moment that i don't know was most
exciting for you or brought you
back to the original movie quicker than
anything else
i have a distinct moment uh i think
for me it was when we said goodbye
at the christmas party right before i
say you know merry christmas
johnny mary's lurie so daniel whatever
but before
that moment she had a moment where i
come back
and say i want to apologize for years
back and she
cuts me off and uh when i turned to
leave it's
such a genuine moment on her face and
they
they put the karate kid little love
story music under it
and it just really was an awe moment for
me like
it's sort of like tied it up and and
and i i didn't know it when we shot it
because i'm leaving and it was push
me turning away and you stay on her for
that moment and there was a whole story
in her eyes there that i thought really
captured the
the heart of that sweet little
adolescent romance from
36 years ago go ahead william yeah
that's a great one um
well the first time i see her when
johnny when they see each other in the
in the cafe is one but i think the time
when it hit me the most was when we were
doing this
scene at golf and stuff after all the
fun and the golfing and all that we're
just sitting down on the bench
and just talking about what our lives
are like today
and as that was happening she's getting
texts from her daughter i'm dealing with
my kids and like real life was happening
and so we had this cross of like
the old and the new coming together in
real life you know while she's playing
ally and playing johnny i'm also playing
dad and we're both in it was like just
so real and and so we we're
sharing something from the past and also
something present now and
in the environment of a of a you know a
ferris wheel and uh the stuffed teddy
bear and
and you know out of golf and stuff it
was i had to pinch myself i thought this
is awesome and and working with her was
just uh
just so much fun and delightful and and
surprisingly cool